but Michael you might say well you  wouldn't say this because you're all  smart and conservative but the squishes  might say this they would say they would  say Michael no  Ben and Jerry's is a private company and  the the private sector can do no wrong  and there's nothing more conservative  than letting leftist corporations do  whatever they want that is the line that  we have been told that is the line that  we conservatives have told ourselves for  the past I don't know 15 or 20 years  increasingly we are seeing how  ridiculous that line of argument is  in some ways conservative Shilling for  big businesses that hate our views and  our country has been more destructive to  the American way of life even than the  leftists big government programs